[Music]
tuesday edition p-f-t-o-t the place
where we drop in the things that we
didn't have time to get to during pft
live chris sims mike florio and you know
one thing that we need to talk about
there's a very large man now playing for
the new york jets and so large that when
he showed up in pads i think people were
stunned at how big he is makai bechten
the new left tackle in new york really
their first marquee left tackle since
the british hall ferguson retired a
little prematurely
uh this is what they need chris the
offensive line if that offense is going
to work if they're going to get value
out of le'veon bell they need a great
offensive line now look
makai bechten isn't going to solve all
five spots but it's an indication that
they're making the investment joe
douglas the gm of the team
building
from the inside out right not from the
outside in
trying to win the way the teams that are
successful always win having a better
offensive line and a better defensive
that's right and that's why we're
talking about it because i think this is
you know one of the staples or
you know things to look forward to if
you're a jets fan
in the joe douglas adam gates era going
forward you know joe douglas you know we
talked about it before he comes from
baltimore he comes from philadelphia
what do they do they kick people's butts
up front that's what their mantras have
been those two teams for you know the
here in in just in the recent past and
really longer than that with the ravens
so yeah this this is the mark that joe
douglas has made his first pick ever is
a mountain of a man and we're talking
about it yeah why because he's a top 10
pick and all that all of that yes but we
heard the rumblings from jets players
after the first padded practice
yesterday about just the sheer presence
of the man and then you know the size
and physicality of the man you know this
is no you know no stay puft marshmallow
man i'll tell you that much this is a
big guy who likes being big and likes
being mean and i think it's just
something to look at to kind of set
forth the new attitude that we might see
from the jets a little bit which is
exciting i mean they couldn't open up a
hole for anything last year for le'veon
bell you know but this year you talk
about mckay beckton and george fanton
free agency and conor mcgovern a big
time guard from the denver broncos you
know alex lewis who was in baltimore
before you know greg van rotten so
they've made a very swot like quiet
under the radar value signings with a
top 10 pick at left tackle to improve
their offensive line to where i think it
is going to make their offense better
and have a different look this year
because i think they'll be able to
depend on that o-line to pass protect
more get keep people out in routes and
of course open up some holes in the run
game
and think back to what quentin nelson's
presence meant for right a couple of
years ago you get that one guy yes who
comes in
and and is going to be mean and he's
going to kick ass and he's going to
attitude center yeah and the other four
guys are going to be the same way they
become a bunch of street fighters i mean
look here's the thing
even though we have seen over the past
11 years the nfl skewed toward a much
kinder and gentler game a game that is
very sensitive to
the potential for long-term trauma head
issues etc
when you're talking about creating
running lanes when you're talking about
protecting the quarterback it is still a
very physical game and you have to
muster the will to go bust someone you
have to be you have to be able to grab a
very large strong man across from you
and throw him onto the ground you have
to have the mindset to do it and makai
beckton is going to set that tone for
the jets ideally and allow them to to be
able to get the most out of lebanon bell
be able to get the most out of sam
darnold be able to get the most out of
their receivers if the offensive line
can get it done like quentin nelson
helped the cults build that wall you're
so fond of yeah well you're right though
he was the attitude setter you know it
took a good offensive line to where we
went whoa
they're like a game-changing offensive
line now and now you can play the game
through them so you can have all these
great you know schematics and the pass
game and all this creative stuff that's
great
every now and then you're gonna play a
defense that's got you know scheme or a
creative coach to take away some of
those schematics
and what the good teams usually have to
fall back on is to go okay some of our
tricks and creativity's not working
today but we still got just good old
smash mouth football where we're gonna
come downhill and bust your you know
just bust your mouth and run for five
yards at a clip you know
like new orleans they're a great example
of that the last two years oh okay yeah
drew brees michael thomas not working
today hey we can run the ball let's just
get back to basics be physical blow
people off the line of scrimmage do that
you know it just gives you another
option and which way to run your team
and really when you have a tough
offensive line
it usually filters through to the rest
of the team because like you said you
know when you have one or two badasses
for lack of a better phrase on that
offensive line the rest of the offensive
line starts to join in on the
badasses-ness right they're all like
i like this guy he's tough he's mean i'm
gonna be like him and be a jerk on the
field too and start playing with the
whistle and pushing people in the ground
but what also happens is then your
defensive line and your linebackers
start to get that same attitude because
they're sick of going against these
freaking guys every day and getting
smushed into the ground and doing that
so now it creates an attitude for them
and that's when you then go oh we're
starting to get some real a really
physical football team it's it's part of
the magic of the baltimore ravens for
the last 20 years right i mean it just
seems like every year they've had the
biggest meanest offensive line and then
oh in turn they have a big mean
defensive line because they got to go
against those guys and that attitude is
set forth you know on a daily basis
offensive line sets the attitude for
practice they really do if they're kind
of having an easy day and going oh we're
going to take care of our body the
defensive line will join in on that fun
and just go okay yeah let's take it easy
today that's cool if the offensive line
is firing out and being jerks it makes
the d-line go damn okay you're gonna
ruin my practice and i'm gonna get made
fun of on film here i gotta dig in and
start to match the intensity level and
it only helps the rest of your football
team
that's right and it gets you ready for
sunday especially if you have a great
offensive line and a great defensive
line because you're practicing against
something better than what you're ever
going to have to face in a game and
that's how a team becomes dominant and
when that happens the quarterback has a
lot of passing yards and touchdowns the
running back has a lot of yards the
receivers do well and those are the guys
who get talked about yeah that's the
great irony of football the key to
success is the the group of five guys
that if they do their jobs to the
highest levels of their abilities nobody
gives a crap about them they care about
the quarterback the running back and the
receivers all right but that's the key
for the jets they they need this badly
joe douglas the gm of the team now needs
to show that he can build the team the
right way they had so many failures from
a personnel standpoint over the past 10
years or longer maybe this is where
things start to turn do not sleep on the
new york jets in 2020. all right don't
sleep on covet 19 either although it's
getting tempting to do so the covet 19
reserve list chris is down to 12. yeah
with all those guys 80 times 32 i don't
have my calculator handy it's a lot of
guys it's well over 2 500 guys that are
in camp 12 are on the covet 19 reserve
list and look that's good that's very
good
now we'll see what happens now that they
have padded practices the nfl has been
very confident that open air
settings
will not be conducive to transmitting
the virus even as guys are coughing and
breathing and spitting and bleeding on
each other they believe it's not going
to transmit the virus and obviously you
need to keep someone who's positive from
slipping through the cracks and getting
out onto the field right let's see if
the numbers change in a negative way in
the coming week or so then the big test
is taking the show on the road and
playing games but you know chris it's
going so well i've heard from people in
the league who are saying quit talking
about how well it's going number one you
don't want to jinx it you know every
sport has that concept thanks but number
two you don't want guys to get
complacent you want guys to be on guard
you want to be to be scared and if the
numbers get to a point where it's no big
deal anymore that's when they open the
door for a problem that that's the big
thing you know again
you know yeah we know there's risk in
playing football and you know hitting
each other and sweating and breathing on
each other all those but if you're doing
all the things right outside of that el
you know that that arena you know then
you don't have to even worry about it
and then and you're going to have to
continue that fight this is going to be
a long haul for the players this year
and you're right i don't want
complacency that way i think the good
thing is mike where you know you look at
the numbers all right and i know like we
haven't practiced practice yet and we
just started
but
i still think there's been a decent
amount of
you know like we watched hard knocks
last week you know jalen ramsey's all
over a receiver and a little one-on-one
drill like yeah they were they were
probably closer than they were allowed
to be at that point but still it was
going on to where you're getting within
that five foot two foot range to breathe
on people and it's encouraging that that
didn't lead to an outbreak or more
issues or anything like that so the one
thing i have heard and i think you're
hearing the same
is really the players are self-policing
themselves and that's what's really good
to hear they're taking it seriously they
realize that the season hinges on their
ability to be
you know what do i want to say dedicated
or just you know
dedicated off the field like they are on
the field and um hey i'm liking it i'm
it's making me feel more and more
hopeful as we go forward
and it is amazing that given that the
country has struggled to get it under
control the nfl even without the
league-wide bubble the nhl they haven't
had a positive test in weeks now the nba
is getting it done baseball is having
their struggles and and i i think in a
weird sort of way
baseball was the wake up call for the
nfl i think you're right to the extent
that anyone needed to know that this
isn't something to mess around with even
if you say well i'm not going to get
sick it doesn't matter if you don't get
sick you're going to play if you're
positive you're not going to play so
that that desire to be available for
your teammates to be available to be out
there that's caused guys to do what they
need to do but you're right chris the
challenge is can they sustain it can you
continue to get the message across the
way they've gotten it across don't get
complacent
and don't get lazy and don't get soft
yeah and don't get to the point where
you think it's not an issue and you know
what the fact that it continues to be an
issue
in our society will keep that from
happening and so you know football hey
football if the world was run by
football coaches the world would be a
hell of a lot better place because
football coaches will tell you the
things that you don't want to hear about
the things that you need to do to get
your stuff together and uh you know we
all i think at some point in life had a
coach whose lessons we still hear all
these years after the fact and it's
beneficial we need to have people
telling us the things we don't want to
hear to tell us to do the things we
don't want to do so we go out and do
them because it's for our own good it's
that simple yeah you're right you know
hopefully the nfl can you know open up
some eyes through society you know and
maybe society can look at it and go wait
wait here's college football they're not
doing anything and wait there's
outbreaks with a lot of teams and things
like that here's the nfl
wearing masks social distancing
still playing football
not having any issue why is that oh
that's right they listen to the people
that are you know um uh oh have brains
and uh know something about the medicine
and science that's right so they've done
that damn how dare they listen to people
with brains and you know a place where
they're very smart in their field so
that to me is going to be a great thing
too to just show people and go look
here's 80 guys tackling each other
breathing on each other nobody's getting
the virus you know why society because
they've done everything up to then right
all the things that we've been told to
do by dr fauci and all the smart people
in our country okay so there we go i'm
done now
uh sometimes it is that simple and
hopefully the nfl becomes and you know
as we're talking about it chris i mean
they're really
again let's not let's not put the cart
before the horse but
but
if this works
this becomes something that can be
parlayed into a stronger message to
society a time when
everyone's caught up in the whole
kneeling thing during the anthem the nfl
has an opportunity to spin this around
and say look if you take it seriously
it's not an issue you can say masks
don't work look at us look at what we've
done we've got the masks we've got the
face shields we're taking the
precautions and the virus isn't in our
building testing and masks testing and
masks instead of being concerned about
testing leading to more cases test and
test and test and test and test to know
who has it contact trace isolate etc and
you understand what you're dealing with
the nfl did it right the end of i look
they did it right they had a plan so far
it's working yeah i don't want to jinx
it so far it's working and maybe it
becomes something that we can be as the
year goes on
telling the rest of the country maybe
you guys should be calling the nfl yeah
maybe you should be talking to them
about what they did because maybe they
got some ideas that'll help us out of
this mess once and for all chris
hopefully we'll be out of this mess
uh but it looks like the nfl well
i guess i feel like i'm jinxing it by
saying it but it looks like the nfl is
gonna yeah just doing it it looks like
we're going to get our game but it just
you know you're right you're we're you
know we're showing again it's just you
know do things the right way and we can
get back to normal we can get you know
not necessarily totally normal but we
can start going that direction if we do
things the right way you know i see it
here like again in the new york
connecticut area as you i've told you
you know people are still really
diligent about it they are when i get
out of work here and go home i'm going
to see people in stanford connecticut
and they'll be everybody on the
sidewalks gonna be wearing masks doing
those type of things i see more cars on
the road going into new york city going
into work doing those type of things you
know so life is getting there you know
but you got to be able to make a few
sacrifices nothing's perfect you know
wear a mask be smart wash your hands
stay away from people don't go in a mosh
pit i don't know just common sense to
things to do during a pandemic no no
mosh pits for you okay at the kiss
concert no no mosh pits for me
lest i jinx it any further i think this
is an appropriate point to end it for
today we'll be back tomorrow with a new
edition of pft live we'll be posting
updates around the clock at
profootballtalk.com everyone stay safe
be smart and look to the nfl for the
guidance on the things that you need to
do to limit the spread of this virus and
maybe we'll all get to the other side of
this thing sooner than later everybody
have a great day we'll see you tomorrow
see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports